Terminator: Dark Fate features some familiar
faces, not just from the beloved action sci-fi
franchise, but from other films and TV shows.
Linda Hamilton and Arnold Schwarzenegger are
joined by a few newcomers you just might recognize
from both the big and small screens.
While it may seem difficult to separate Hamilton
from the role of Sarah Connor - badass action
icon and protagonist of the first two Terminator
movies - she's had memorable roles both before
and after 1984's The Terminator.
She starred as Vicky in the 1984 horror film
Children of the Corn, and, between 1987 and
1990, she starred opposite Ron Perlman on
CBS' Beauty and the Beast.
In 1997, she starred with Pierce Brosnan and
Jaime Renée Smith in the disaster thriller
hit Dante's Peak.
She hit the small screen in a big way in 2010,
appearing on two episodes of Weeds and scoring
a recurring role on NBC's Chuck as a CIA agent
and Chuck's estranged mother.
In recent years, she's nabbed a recurring
antagonist spot on Syfy's Defiance and a prominent
guest role on the supernatural drama Lost
Girl.
"I'll be back."
The athletic woman we see going head-to-head
with the new Terminator in the teaser is Grace,
played by Mackenzie Davis.
As of her appearance in Dark Fate, Davis'
professional film acting career is just under
a decade old.
Her first starring film role came in 2013
with the romantic drama Breathe In.
She appeared as Miles Teller's friend and
eventual love interest in 2014's That Awkward
Moment.
Davis' tireless engineer Mindy Park played
a key role in getting Matt Damon's astronaut
Mark home in 2015's The Martian.
Mindy Park wasn't her last nerdy role - from
2014 to 2017, she played programmer Cameron
on AMC's Halt and Catch Fire.
She achieved even more small screen exposure
when she starred alongside Gugu Mbatha-Raw
in "San Junipero," hailed by many as the finest
episode of Black Mirror.
If you're excited for Terminator: Dark Fate,
you may have already caught another long-awaited
science fiction sequel dealing with complex
questions about artificial intelligence.
That brings us to one of Mackenzie Davis'
most prominent roles to date: Mariette, a
replicant freedom fighter in Blade Runner
2049.
Terminator: Dark Fate introduces us to Rev
9, an advanced Terminator model played by
Gabriel Luna, who you should definitely recognize
if you're a Marvel TV fan.
Luna appeared in the fourth season of Marvel's
Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D. as Robbie Reyes, a.k.a.
the supernatural vigilante Ghost Rider.
Over his season-long arc, Reyes - having been
granted the power of the Spirit of Vengeance
after getting murdered by a street gang - helps
S.H.I.E.L.D.
tackle a few supernatural threats before exiting
the show with the season 4 finale.
Before playing Ghost Rider, Luna starred in
ABC's short-lived crime procedural Wicked
City as Detective Paco Contreras.
Fans of the El Rey Network may also recognize
him as Tony Bravo, the soccer star who doubles
as a CIA operative in Matador.
He appeared in 2011's dark comedy Bernie - the
real life story of a mortician who befriends
and later murders an eccentric millionaire
- and starred alongside Johnny Simmons and
Clifton Collins Jr. in the 2016 thriller Transpecos,
the story of border patrol agents embroiled
in a conflict against a drug cartel.
The woman who Grace and Sarah Connor are risking
everything to protect is Dani Ramos.
Dani is played by Natalia Reyes, a Colombian
actress whose fame has yet to find a sure
foothold with American audiences, but whose
talents have already made her a star in her
native country.
Reyes is perhaps best known for her starring
role in the Colombian telenovela Lady, La
Vendedora de Rosas, the fascinating and tragic
true story of Lady Maria Tabares, a famous
Colombian actress who was sentenced to 26
years in prison for ordering the murder of
a taxicab driver.
More recently, Reyes starred in the critically-hailed
crime epic Birds of Passage, which gained
her much more international attention, including
in the States.
We hope Arnold Schwarzenegger looks familiar.
If he doesn't, hey, we're not judging, but
it's just kind of a mystery why you're interested
in Terminator: Dark Fate at all.
Maybe you thought it was a really hardcore
pest control service?
We don't know.
Schwarzenegger's first film was his starring
role in 1970's Hercules in New York.
His prominence as the action hero of the eighties
began with 1984's Conan the Barbarian, in
which he played the savage warrior of Robert
E. Howard's fiction.
That same year he starred as the ruthless
cyborg hunting Sarah Connor in James Cameron's
The Terminator, truly cementing his status
as a pop culture icon.
"I'll be back."
Ironically, while the first Terminator film
did so much for his career, he didn't play
bad guys much after that.
Throughout the '80s and '90s, he battled mercenaries
in Commando, hunted a monster in The Predator,
won a deadly game show in The Running Man,
got his ass to Mars in Total Recall, and failed
to keep the wool over Jamie Lee Curtis' eyes
in True Lies.
Through it all, he made the delivery of violent
yet corny one-liners into an art all its own.
As he grew in fame, he was successful in a
couple of memorable comedies as well, namely
1988's Twins and 1990's Kindergarten Cop.
More recently, Schwarzenegger has been a regular
fixture in the Expendables franchise and turned
in a surprisingly subtle performance in 2015's
low-key zombie drama Maggie.
Oh yeah, and between 2003 and 2011, he was
busy being the 38th governor of California.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.